Pitched as the “ultimate sport”, chess
boxing is – depending on who you ask – either
a seamless blend of the cerebral and the physical
or a joke that got kinda out of hand…
Formally invented in the early 2000s, chess
boxing is the brainchild of a Dutch artist
Iepe Rubingh who has since recognised the
appeal of chess boxing as a spectator sport
and worked towards legitimising it as an athletic
pursuit.
First though, for anyone unfamiliar with the
sport, chess boxing is described simply by
one of the governing bodies of the sport as
“11 alternating 3 minute rounds of chess
and boxing”.
As per the rules, a traditional chess boxing
bout begins with a round of chess (specifically
speed chess where turn times are limited)
which is then immediately followed by a 3
minute round of boxing.
Chess boxers are given only limited time to
compose themselves between rounds, during
which time the chess board is moved either
from or into the centre of the ring.
Victory in chess boxing can be achieved via
either a checkmate, one’s opponent exceeding
the time limit on their chess clock, or knockout
and if a bout happens to go the full 11 rounds,
it will be scored like a traditional boxing
match.
This said, points can be deducted from a player
for doing things like stalling for time during
the chess rounds which could cost them the
win if the fight does go to a judge’s decision.
In addition, victory can be achieved by stoppage,
technical knockout, or the disqualification
of an opponent.
As you might expect, chess boxers must wear
boxing gloves during the boxing portions of
a chess boxing bout, one or both of which
can be removed for comfort’s sake during
chess rounds to make moving pieces easier.
Further, to maintain the purity of the one-on-one
nature of chess boxing bouts, during chess
rounds chess boxers are required to wear headphones
to prevent people, including audience members,
from giving them advice.
No doubt with screaming fans and overly enthusiastic
commentators not far away, tuning all that
out via the headphones also probably helps
the chess boxers focus.
Of course, for safety’s sake, the headphones
are removed for the boxing portions of a chess
boxing bout, meaning a chess boxer could theoretically
get advice on what move to make next while
boxing.
Then again, someone able to parse technical
chess jargon over the roar of a crowd while
simultaneously being punched in the face is
probably someone who possesses a mind keen
enough to succeed at chess without advice,
so we guess that’s fine.
Speaking of mental toughness, this in fact
is touted by many a chess boxer as one of
the most difficult aspects of the sports-
having to switch between amping your body
up for a physical fight, and then as quickly
as possible calming down to direct a cool,
collected mind at the fight on the board.
Or as it states on the official Chess Boxing
Global website,
Chess Boxing is a rare blend of contrasting
skills.
The athlete combines a powerful body with
a sharp mind, and rises above mindless muscle.
In the ring, the fighter is fueled by testosterone,
adrenaline and skill.
Three minutes later, he changes battlegrounds.
The contender has only seconds to restrain
his fighting instinct and move into the silent
logic of his mind.
Chessboxers need smartness for solving problems;
They must anticipate their opponent’s moves
in the ring, as well as on the board.
It is the only sport in which the heart, mind
and body perform in total harmony.
This is the ultimate battle.
With that out of the way, you may now be wondering
where in the hell such a bizarre idea came
from?
The answer to which is rather fittingly- a
comic book.
You see, according to Rubingh chess boxing’s
genesis can be directly traced to a French
comic released in 1992 called Froid Équateur
(literally – “Cold Equator”) which is
set in the post apocalyptic future hellscape
of 2034.
In the comic, chess boxing features heavyweight
boxers beating the living crap out of each
other on a giant chessboard.
In an interview with The Guardian Rubingh
notes that he was intrigued by the idea of
chess boxing after stumbling across Froid
Équateur in his father’s comic collection
as a teenager and was keen to make some version
of it into an actual sport.
A performance artist and natural comedian
at heart, Rubingh is known in the art world
for his numerous, often humorous, performance
art pieces.
In fact, one such instance actually saw him
acquire the moniker “The Joker”, which
he’s still known by to this day.
This was a result of a time he blocked off
an intersection in downtown Tokyo with police
tape.
Naturally, the stunt earned Rubingh a ten
day jail sentence, which is what he was originally
going for.
The joke in all this was he spent the duration
of his time in jail dressed in a traditional
jester’s outfit, hence the subsequent nickname.
Chess boxing has similar origins and was likewise
intended to begin life as a performance art
piece, with the artist hoping the absurdity
of the whole thing would do what all art intends
to do and make people think.
To quote Rubingh himself,
We tend to divide everything into different
worlds, but in my opinion worlds are much
more connected than people see them at first.
Chess boxing breaks through this habit.
So many people say to me: ‘Chess and boxing,
they just don’t fit together,’ and some
chess players hate the idea, but they forget
that former world boxing champion Lennox Lewis
and current champion Vitali Klitschko both
play chess.
Boxing is about the control of aggression,
and chess boxing is 200% about the control
of aggression.
All this said, to Rubingh’s surprise, chess
boxing turned out to be a hit, with the first
official chess boxing bout in a Berlin art
gallery, pitting Rubingh against a friend
called Jean Louis Veenstra, proving to be
bizarre enough a concept that it actually
packed the gallery to capacity.
Spurred by the unexpected success of the joke,
Rubingh decided to try and turn his creation
into a legitimate sport, holding the first
official Chess Boxing World Championship later
that same year in Amsterdam, drawing a crowd
of over a thousand people.
Officially endorsed by both the Dutch Chess
Federation and Dutch Boxing Association, Rubingh
once again put on the gloves and fought Veenstra
for the championship.
Styling himself as Iepe the Joker for the
bout, Veenstra (or Luis the Lawyer as he’s
known in the ring) fought a vicious battle
on both the canvas and chessboard with Rubingh
eventually emerging victorious- meaning that
not only is Rubingh the inventor of chess
boxing, he’s its first champion.
Of his victory in the match, Rubingh notes,
“I had a pretty terrible position on the
board so in the last round I tried to knock
him out.
He only just managed to stay on his feet.
The bell went and he put his hands up in the
air but he couldn’t find his corner.
He was really dizzy but we still had to play
the final round of chess.
There was a clear win for him, but he just
couldn’t figure out the right moves.”
Rubingh has since abandoned art almost entirely
to focus on promoting chess boxing as a legitimate
sporting pursuit, founding the World Chess
Boxing Organisation.
As a nod to the sport’s origins, Rubingh
made sure to found this organisation in Berlin
and saw to it that the first honorary chairman
of the WCBO was Froid Équateur creator Enki
Bilal.
Thanks to these efforts, chess boxing is now
a legitimate sporting endeavour that while
having admittedly niche appeal at present,
has a thriving and rapidly growing pool of
chess boxing talent that now tallies over
2,000 athletes across the world, with India
seeing the largest group with over 600 people
competing in the sport.